antoine bonjour les autorités russes
viennent d'annoncer des contres
sanctions dans le cadre de cette affaire
la vanille oui tout à fait dans la
matinée les ambassadeurs de la france de
l'allemagne et de la suède ont été
convoqués au ministère russe des
affaires étrangères il aurait été
communiqué la position de moscou sur le
sujet et de nouvelles mesures leur ont
été signifiées
en réponse aux sanctions adoptées par
l'union européenne contre la russie des
sanctions illégales aux yeux de moscou
regarder nous considérons qu'il est
catégoriquement inacceptable qu'à
l'initiative de ses principaux états
membres l'union européenne prenne des
mesures restrictives illégales à
l'encontre d'un certain nombre de nos
compatriotes
sous prétexte de leur implication
présumée dans l'incident concernant le
citoyen russe alexeï navalni de plus les
pays à l'origine d'une telle démarche
n'ont pas fourni de preuves dans le
cadre de cette affaire non seulement aux
autorités russes
malgré nos demandes répétées mais même à
leurs propres partenaires au sein de
lieux
en conséquence les autorités russes ont
décidé sur la base du principe de
réciprocité d'élargir la liste des
ressortissant d'états membres de l'union
européenne interdit de séjour sur le
territoire russe d'après le ministère
cette liste inclut ceux qui ont
contribué à l'escaladé y aura mené à
l'adoption de ses sanctions contre la
russie ces mesures du ministère russe
des affaires étrangères
apparaissent au lendemain de nouveaux
développements dans la sphère la vanille
celui ci prétend en effet avoir piégé au
téléphone un agent du fsb responsable
d'après lui de son empoisonnement
une annonce qui a provoqué une réaction
de la part du porte parole du kremlin
écoutez je me permet d'exprimer une
opinion personnelle
le malade souffre manifestement d'un
délire de la persécution et de certains
symptômes de mégalomanie même si la
situation prend de l'ampleur sur le plan
diplomatique les différentes parties
restent campées sur leurs positions
depuis berlin l'opposant russe continue
de tenter de prouver qu'il a bel et bien
été empoisonnés
tandis que moscou dément toujours toute
implication merci beaucoup antoine
gayraud pour toute ces
précision en direct de moscou